less how star wars for the first time it
was all practical and real you knew it
when you saw the movie so I felt that
the standard had to be authentically the
standard had to be reality
we want to make sure that wherever we
went in this movie always felt they were
really there we needed to find somewhere
completely from another time of place
Rick castle
stumbled across a picture of the skellig
michael which is an island of the Irish
coast I got an email from Rick Carter
he sent this link and it was scelc
Island then JJ immediately wrote back
and said I love you only this is the
best starwars what's so great is places
matter they actually are really related
to who the characters are I remember
when we all flew in it was special and
we knew it I can't believe that shoot
there I mean it was it was so beautiful
we were just blown away by it is it's an
extraordinary place it certainly fed
into our Star Wars universe an Irish
Film Board were behind us 1,000%
to countless hours to pull off what we
needed to ask Alec
very very happy to be here on skellig
michael today with JJ Abrams and hands a
wonderful Star Wars film which is
shooting on this island it's just
amazing the scenery is amazing their
heritage is amazing and the way people
are going to see in the beauty of this
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie hopefully you
guys have had a chance to see Star Wars
The Force awakens it's now like one of
the biggest movies ever in the history
of the world but I thought it'd be fun
to talk a little bit about some of the
Luke Skywalker Jedi BTS from the movie
this is just a fun behind the scenes on
Selig Michael which is actually a really
important island in the history of
Ireland itself which tells you a little
bit about the way they use it in the
movie now they don't really talk about
it in this video but the island itself
was home to this ancient Christian
monastery but even before that it's said
to be the final resting place of this
really important progenitor of Irish
culture so in the movie Luke Skywalker
travels to this place looking for the
original Jedi Temple for the beginnings
of Jedi culture so you can see how the
real world significance of the island
becomes really special significance for
the movie back to the beginning of
things that's why in the video they said
they had to get special permission to
shoot there and they've already been
back there since they finished filming
episode 7 to film or episode eight
scenes Mark Hamill had to grow his
obi-wan Kenobi Luke Skywalker beard back
and I'll just say it real quick spoiler
warning for Episode seven I'll be
talking about specific things from the
force awakens so we know that before the
events of Episode seven then when he
split from Luke Skywalker's new Jedi
Order destroyed the temple so at some
point the Jedi will probably flourish
again in the galaxy it'll all probably
start back at this place now as much as
we've been picking the movie apart we
haven't been talking too much about the
nature of the force in this new trilogy
and JJ Abrams confirmed they didn't
throw out all of the Lucas Canon from
the prequels like the big addition that
George Lucas made to the force in the
prequels was qui-gon jinn talking about
the Living force now there are two main
aspects to the force they discuss in the
film's if you go into the expanded
universe which is now you know
technically not Canon there's a third
aspect to the force when obi-wan Kenobi
is telling Luke Skywalker in Episode
four about the force being this energy
field that penetrates and binds all
living things in the galaxy he's
technically talking about the Living
force it gets a little backwards with
qui-gon jinn in the prequels because
when qui-gon jinn talks about the Living
force there's also the cosmic force
which is kind of the new idea that's the
midi-chlorian part of the force like the
conscious part of the force that
communicates to individuals through
midi-chlorians now already this sounds a
little bit complicated which is why I
think wisely the new movie doesn't even
try
address it I think it's to their benefit
to not over explain the force but that's
what all the novels are for and now that
we know that Ray is going to be a Jedi
we know all about kylo Ren the Knights
of Ren supreme leader snoke the expanded
novels will probably start pushing into
that even though Anakin Skywalker is the
big figure of the prequels it's all
about introducing his character his rise
and fall I think that obi-wan Kenobi is
actually one of the bigger protagonists
of the prequels because in it he learns
about the different aspects of the force
and it's in that time between Episode
three in Episode four where obi-wan
Kenobi is growing old on Tatooine
waiting for Luke Skywalker to grow up
that he is learning about the Living
force
communicating with the force through
midi-chlorians to learn how to become a
force ghost and in order to become a
force ghost you have to understand the
Living force now they actually addressed
this in the Clone Wars season six if you
haven't seen it they released it on DVD
I think it's on Netflix too you might be
able to watch it on Netflix but in it
Yoda learns about the Living force and
learns how to create force ghosts you
learn all about force spirits that is
all thankfully still canon I know
everybody always wonders about the Clone
Wars Clone Wars is still canon how did
you know Jamie King did the voice of all
five of them Jamie had a great says
she's someone that can take on that
challenge and you know we had to come up
with these archetype voices for each of
the identities I don't want to ruin any
greater mystery of this whole thing for
you but the way that I reconciled what
that being is is actually one being it's
one ancient being separate over time
that for our perception to be able to
see her she is these many different
iconic things presented to us but she
died a long long long long long time ago
she is
conscious in the force and she has a
limited ability to manifest what we're
getting at is why Yoda and obi-wan are
able to do this and why other people
can't there's an exist as it's been done
before it's been done before when he
learns it
it's unsettling so you're not sure when
you was talking to her is she good is
she evil again because we're thinking in
those terms and that being is not
existing on those terms really a lot of
you have been asking the really
important question are we gonna see
force ghosts in the new trilogy I would
say probably at some point the closest
we got was when Rey had the force
visions where the lightsaber gave her
the visions technically you would say
the midi-chlorians gave her visions but
I think it's to the benefit of the new
trilogy to just not mention them
specifically very controversial
midi-chlorians but I mean just because
they don't mention them doesn't mean
they don't exist it's just a way to
explain how the force communicates with
people now there's an extra aspect of
the force that the expanded universe
novels get into called the unifying
force where it's like a combination of
the dark side and the light side of the
force in the novels Jason solo attains a
more complete understanding of the force
than anyone's ever had before and
becomes this super Jedi where he can
harness the dark and the light that is
kind of where they're going with the
kylo Ren character based on what Supreme
Leader Snoke is talking about in the
novelization of the movie I've done a
couple easter-egg videos that I'll put
links for in the description but in it I
talked a little bit about how Snoke
really likes kylo Ren because he started
out as a light side Jedi he hasn't
always been a darkside Jedi
it sounds like Snoke wants to create
this super Jedi and he needs someone who
can balance the light side in the dark
side now Snoke is the big villain of the
movie so obviously he wants to use kylo
Ren for some sinister purpose but if you
take the position that Rey and kylo Ren
are on parallel arcs then reign kylo Ren
will be this conduit for the new trilogy
to give us this more complete
understanding of the forest the forest
is grand and mysterious it's much more
complex than this binary good evil light
dark thing we've been led to believe by
previous films but that's just because
we haven't seen characters explore it
yet which is where I think they're
headed with Luke Skywalker trying to go
back to the original Jedi Temple trying
to learn things that were lost over time
you get the sense from the prequels that
the Jedi have become so dogmatic that
they just completely shut off certain
areas of study if you're a big Game of
Thrones fan the maesters
or a good analog for that like the
maesters absolutely hate magic in Game
of Thrones they really like science
really hate anything mystical so the
Jedi have the prequels just have like
certain aspects of the force they don't
want people studying or learning about
meaning that new students have a lesser
understanding so I'm just I'm really
hoping that we get to push into really
mysterious aspects of the force let me
know in the comments though what do you
guys want to see the new films do with
the force as a story device in this new
trilogy
now obviously episodes 8 and 9 of the
anthology films that's where most of the
big storytelling is gonna happen but
that doesn't mean the spin-off films
like rogue one or the Han Solo film
won't have anything to do with the force
one of my favorite things that I heard
from people that work inside the Star
Wars franchise is the idea that Han Solo
might be using the force without
realizing it like he just he doesn't
understand it he's like this crazy
mumbo-jumbo religion but the idea is
that Han Solo is such a good pilot that
maybe when he's getting his jam on with
the Millennium Falcon
he's using the force without realizing
it that is the backdoor for Finn to be
force sensitive I know everyone wants to
know is Finn force sensitive he was
using the lightsaber he was pretty good
with it he's a highly trained
stormtrooper so he's a good fighter
anyway but maybe he is also force
sensitive the reason I think they didn't
try to answer that right away is because
they just wanted him to be a badass
without being a Jedi they wanted you to
focus on Rey being the new Jedi but when
Supreme Leader Snoke said there's been
an awakening have you felt it to kylo
Ren I think he was talking about more
than just the Rey character but what I'm
expecting from episode 9 is for them to
just kind of tease that out a little bit
more we'll get to see a lot of Jedi a
lot of Darkseid training kylo Ren needs
to finish his training just like Rey
needs to start her training so let's
just speculate away in the comments this
is gonna be one of the most fun things
to do between films just trying to
speculate about where they're going with
Jedi with Darkseid force users what
happened to the Sith it sounds like the
Sith are gone and the Knights of Ren 2
replaced them but I guess we'll find out
and congratulations to last week's
giveaway winner Bruno Lopez you and the
IMAX gift certificate just be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact info
just in case you guys haven't seen them
I've done three Easter egg videos you
can click here for that it's like my big
Star Wars playlist and you can click
here to learn all about Spider Man
in Captain America's Civil War thank you
so much watching everybody I'll see you
guys tonight